The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LING REN: All right,
welcome everyone.
This is 6046 presentation.
Just make sure you're
in the right place.
My name is Ling Ren.
I'm one of the 10
TAs for this class.
We do have a second
TA for this section.
I think he is not
here right now,
but, basically,
[INAUDIBLE] and I will
be switching every other week.
I want to remind
you, just a heads up,
this section is recorded
for OCW purpose.
But I think he's only
recording us, the TAs.
You're not in a camera.
All right, so, the only
purpose we are here
is to help you learn this very
interesting, and also very
useful, class.
So don't hesitate
to ask any questions
or give us any feedback,
like whether I'm
going too fast or too slow,
whether you want us to cover
something that's not
in the posted schedule,
or just anything we can help.
All right, so let's get started.
The two lectures in this
week, in the first week,
focus on divide and conquer.
It is a class of algorithm
that usually involves recursion
in the algorithm description.
And Professor Devadas worked
through several algorithms,
including weighted
interval scheduling
and a bunch of others, and he
left several open problems.
So we will answer those open
questions in this section,
and we'll also show
you a new algorithm,
and analyze a bunch
of other algorithms.
So just to remind everyone what
weighted interval scheduling
is.
In this problem, we are
given a bunch of requests,
each with a start time
and a finish time.
And our goal is to find a subset
of them that are compatible,
meaning they do not
overlap, and that
have a largest combined weight.
OK, are we clear?
Everyone clear about that?
So an easier case
is when the problem
is unweighted, meaning that
every task has the same weight.
In that case, we can just solve
it using our greedy algorithm.
But when the problem
becomes weighted,
we have to use dynamic
programming, or recursion,
and Srini introduced a
simple one, a basic version,
in a class.
Can someone remind us
how that algorithm works?
Any volunteers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Can you speak louder?
so we find that it's
not conflicting [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: So what's your name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Yeah, I think
the version you described
is for the unweighted case.
In unweighted case,
we just schedule
the 1 with the
earliest finish time,
and, then, we remove all
the incompatible ones,
and we keep going, right?
That solved the
unweighted version.
If it's the weighted version,
we need to use recursion.
And remember, we break the
problem into many sub-problems,
and each one can potentially
be an optimal solution.
Does anyone remember that?
Care to give it a try?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So we break it into subproblems.
We took the best solution
from a certain point,
and then we calculate
that subproblem
starting at all the
different finish times.
[INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Great.
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: [? Amin. ?]
LING REN: [? Amin? ?] OK.
[? Amin ?] said, let's
just try every one
as our potential first request.
So if we request the j as
our first, we get its weight.
And then, we're going
to solve a subproblem.
So let me call the
original problem.
We did interval scheduling
with all the incoming requests.
Now, we choose j,
request as our first.
Now, we are left with a
subproblem that starts
after request to j finishes.
So I'll write that
as Rj, Where I
define Rj to be the set of
requests where their stop
time is later than the finish
time of the j-th request.
OK, so just to repeat,
we choose a request,
has the potential to
be the first request,
and then, we look at all the
requests that start after it,
and solve a subproblem
of that case.
Then, we take a max of
all the candidate we have,
and that's going to give
us the optimal solution.
Any question about
this algorithm?
So this algorithm
runs in n square time.
Now, we're going to try to
optimize that, and come up
with a better algorithm.
So in order to improve
anything, we first
want to identify the
inefficiency in this algorithm.
So which part in
the algorithm do you
think is inefficient,
or silly, unnecessary?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So it's
inefficient to look
through every previous
subproblem, when we're trying
to find maximum [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: I was
saying that we don't
need to go through
every of this case.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
we shouldn't Well,
we should be able to efficiently
query for the right one.
LING REN: OK, I think you
are definitely correct.
So let me just go through what
this algorithm does, and it
will be more clear.
So what this means is, I'll
choose the first request.
I'll request 1 as
my first request.
Then, I'm going to consider
only the requests that
start after 1 finishes, right?
That only leaves request a 5.
Potentially some other's
already been drawn there.
That's my first
candidate in that max.
My second candidate is actually
request 2 as my first request.
Then, I have to remove request
1, because it starts too early,
and then, I'm left with
all the remaining requests.
I'll solve that subproblem.
That's candidate 2.
Candidate 3, I chose request
3 as my first request,
and then I have
to remove 1 and 2,
because they start too early.
Oh, 4 as well.
It also starts too early, right?
Before 3 finishes.
Everyone following that?
So we're left with
the remaining request.
Is it more clear now?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So candidate, if
you start with 3, that's
actually a subproblem of 2.
[INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Great point.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Andrew.
LING REN: Andrew said,
we can potentially
be solving many repeated
subproblems, like this.
We definitely don't
want to do that.
And that's actually the core
idea, the one crisp idea
of dynamic programming.
Andrew, can you tell me
what's the definition
of dynamic programming?
You remember?
Anyone remember that?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Just memorize
subproblems, then look them up.
LING REN: Exactly.
So dynamic programming says,
we will break a problem
into subproblems,
and subproblems
into even more subproblems,
but whenever we solve one,
we should memorize, or
just remember its result
and store it somewhere.
And if you need it again,
we'll just retrieve it,
without resolving the problem.
That's definitely a great point.
So we can analyze the
complexity of this algorithm
later, because I want
to touch on this more
efficient algorithm first.
And we'll see that, even
after Andrew's optimization,
its runtime is n square.
So without that
observation, if we
are solving repeated
subproblems,
these will be a lot
worse than that.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You can also trim
ones that get to the same place,
so you don't need to
explore two paths.
LING REN: Sorry, say that again?
AUDIENCE: You don't need
to explore two paths that
[INAUDIBLE] both exploring 3.
Once they're both looking
at 3, then you only
need to do the ones more
efficient to that point.
LING REN: OK, cool.
Go ahead.
Oh, same thing?
AUDIENCE: Well, I have
another one as well.
So I think to get
better than n squared,
we need to make the observation
that it's always fine to start
a subproblem later.
So if you've decided
you're taking
a certain sequence of intervals
from your first interval,
and then you want to see
how to compute from there,
it's always valid to start
later than, maybe, you had to.
So that means that
if we can efficiently
starting at any
particular point,
query for the maximum of any
of the subproblems starting
after that point, then
we can [INAUDIBLE]..
LING REN: OK, great.
I think we are on the same page.
So when I describe the
steps of this algorithm,
remember this third candidate.
I choose this as
my first, right?
It makes zero sense,
because, if I do that,
I might as well
put in 2, as well.
Doesn't hurt, right?
Everyone get that?
So the idea is that we
shouldn't try every possible W
request as my first.
Some requests are
just better, more
suited to be the first request.
And how we're going to do that?
So, apparently,
1 can potentially
be the first request.
2 can also be.
But it doesn't make any
sense for any requests
come after that, because
there's and earlier request.
So the efficient
algorithm, let's
first sort them by
their start time.
We're going to consider the
request that comes early first.
So I have my entire
problem, here.
Now, I'm going to
ask a question.
Should I include request
1 in my solution or not?
That's only two cases.
So if I do not select 1 in
my solution, what subproblem
am I left with?
Any idea?
If I decide I will not
include 1 in my solution.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Yeah, exactly.
There's no conflicts anywhere.
I'll solve a
subproblem from 2 to n.
If I do decide to put my
request 1 in a solution,
I get this weight.
So what's the subproblem
I'm left with?
Yeah, in this
example, it's five.
Correct.
But more generally--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] So every
request that starts afterward.
LING REN: Exactly, every request
that starts after 1 finishes.
Now, suddenly, we are not
breaking the original problem
into n subproblems.
We only have two subproblems.
So let me draw a
recursion tree, which
is a powerful tool in
analyzing these sort of things.
So we start with our original
problem, from 1 to n,
and we have two subproblems,
2 to n and R1 to n.
This one, we'll also break
them into subproblems.
So what is this one?
OK, I have my sub
problem 2 to n,
and I need to further
reapply the same trick
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The max of Wi has to be--
LING REN: Oh, sorry.
These are the two cases.
Either I do not schedule
my first, or I schedule it,
and this is my first request.
Now, here, I'm left
with this problem.
Either I do not schedule
it, or I schedule it
as my first request.
So what is this one?
AUDIENCE: Probably
be 3 to the n.
LING REN: 3 to n,
because now I'm
asking the same question for 2.
And, here, I'll have R2
to n, so on and so forth.
Now, let me point out the big
difference for this version,
and for the basic version.
So I'm starting with the
request that starts first.
If I do not do
that, say, if here,
I am asking the question for
5, do I schedule 5 as my first
or not?
Then, what happens?
Then, these two branches
do not cover all the cases,
because I can
potentially schedule it,
but not as my first, in
the optimal solution,
if I'm asking a question
for a random request.
However, if I start with the
first request, first meaning it
starts earliest, it will
either be not scheduled,
or it will be scheduled,
and as the first.
Because it cannot be the
second request in my solution.
Any questions about
this algorithm?
OK, now, this is the algorithm.
Let's analyze its complexity.
So what's the
overall complexity.
when we go all the
way down, solve
the entire original problem?
Any guesses?
What do you think?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It should be log
n, because [INAUDIBLE] sort
the intervals, and we're going
to need to, for every interval,
find the next interval
that starts after it,
and do that for [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Cool.
So the first step is
sorting, which is n log n.
Now, after I sort everything,
the question I need to answer
is, how many unique
subproblems are there,
in this entire recursion tree?
So I'm not going to solve
the same problem twice.
How many unique
problems exist, here?
n of them, right?
Just this left branch.
All the others will
be one of these.
So I can start from the bottom
of the tree and work my way up,
and when I want
to take this step,
I'll look up the
result of this in one
of the subproblems
I've already solved.
So, actually, the recursion
itself is only O of n.
AUDIENCE: I missed
when you said, what
is the sorting referring to?
LING REN: OK, so we need to
start with the request that
starts first, right?
We need to decide whether
we schedule it or not.
And, then, we need to do the
same thing for this request 2.
It's the start earliest
request in this subset.
We always need to do that
for all the subproblems.
So the overall
complexity is n log n.
But if we only focus
on this recursion step,
our improvement is
actually larger than that,
because it went from
n square to O of n.
So why is the original
algorithm n squared?
I think it also has only n
unique subproblems, right?
So do you agree that the
original algorithm is n
squared, or do you
think it's also O of n?
Just focus on the
recursion step.
AUDIENCE: Didn't the
original algorithm
solve some subproblems
up to n times?
So that's why it's
still of n squared,
because it solved
the same thing?
LING REN: But
assuming I do not do
that, assuming, whenever
I solve it once,
I store the result somewhere,
and I directly get it.
Assuming I do that,
what's the complexity?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: O of n.
LING REN: You think it's O of n?
So anyone think it's n squared?
Because I think Srini
said it's n squared.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think the
original algorithm isn't
[INAUDIBLE] squared,
because we're still
doing [INAUDIBLE] for every
subproblem [INAUDIBLE]..
LING REN: Exactly right.
So, here, whenever
we go up one step,
I'm doing constant
number of work.
Just comparing two numbers
and taking the max.
However, in the
original algorithm,
which is here, whenever
I want to go one step up,
there are n branches
of the tree.
So my total amount of work is
1 plus 2 plus 3 plus n, right?
Every step becomes
harder when I go up.
And this is n squared.
Any questions about that?
OK, this is so much for our
weighted interval scheduling.
Now, I'm going to transition
into the next topic.
So any question on
the side, in general,
for the scheduling problem?
Do you have a question?
No?
OK, now, let's turn to a second
topic of this section, which
is Strassen algorithm.
Strassen algorithm is
an efficient algorithm
for matrix multiplication,
and matrix multiplication
is a really useful primitive.
It has applications in almost
every area I can think of.
Circuit simulation,
climate simulation,
and physics,
basically everything.
Now, I actually
had some experience
with matrix multiplication,
because my undergrad research
was improving matrix algorithms.
And, actually, many
matrix algorithms,
including inversion,
solving equations,
they all use multiplication
as a primitive.
So it actually comes
down to improving
matrix multiplication.
And I tried very hard to just
optimize this basic matrix
multiplication.
We'll take a row,
you take a column,
and then you get your
answer for this spot.
Everyone's familiar
with that, right?
I tried very hard,
but it's still
100 x slower than the
best algorithm out there.
So I finally look it up, and
I was completely mind-blown
when I know that matrix
algorithm complexity is not
n cubic.
It's actually smaller than that.
Is this a surprise to you?
Anyone expect that before?
And the technique the more
efficient algorithm uses
is, exactly, Strassen algorithm.
Now that we're talking
about divide and conquer,
you can guess it must be a
divide and conquer algorithm.
And, so, does
anyone have an idea
how to divide the
original problem?
Anyone want to give it a try?
So are you familiar with
tiled matrix multiplication,
or blocked matrix
multiplication?
OK, can you tell
us what that is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You can break it
into [INAUDIBLE]..
LING REN: OK, so say
this is our A and B,
and we want C. We can break
each matrix into four parts.
I'll call this
A11, A12, A21, A22.
B11, B12, B21, B22.
Same thing for C.
Now, I would like someone
to tell me, what is C11,
in this case?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A11 [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: A12, B21, yep.
And C12 is--
Just speak up, don't be shy.
This is also my first
section ever, in my life,
teaching a recitation.
I'm more nervous than you guys.
What is C12?
AUDIENCE: A11, B12?
LING REN: A11, B12.
A12, B22, right?
So the rule is the
same as before.
Matrix multiplication.
Compute this, we take
this row, this column,
and it gives us this.
AUDIENCE: So the
first one [INAUDIBLE]..
LING REN: Right, thank you.
A12, B21.
OK.
And, same thing,
C21, we're going
to take this row
and this column.
A21 B11 plus A22 B21.
C11 is A21 B12 plus A22 B22.
OK.
And everyone understands this?
OK, great.
So, now, we've broken
up the original problem
into several subproblems.
We only need to do matrix
multiplication here
eight times.
And each of this
matrix is half in size.
If the original
algorithm is n cubic,
now each sub problem
is half n cubic.
Then we have eight of them,
so the complexity is still
n cubic.
No improvement at all.
So, actually, to
be more precise,
we can further break up these
matrices into smaller blocks.
So, to be precise,
its complexity
should be given by a recursion.
Eight subproblems, each
one half the size, plus--
can anyone tell me?
What's the merging complexity,
once I get all this?
[INAUDIBLE]
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is it just constant
because you're adding?
LING REN: Yeah,
because I'm adding.
But is it constant?
I'm adding these two matrices.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: For each
level it can base case?
LING REN: Yeah, for base case,
it's, of course, constant.
OK, so maybe I'm not
clear about this.
What's the subproblem,
in this case?
It's this multiplication
operation, OK?
And, so, these are the eight
subproblems I will solve.
After solving them, I
need to add them together.
And adding two matrices,
and each is size ha;f of n.
The complexity is--
AUDIENCE: n squared 2 over 2?
LING REN: Yeah, it's n squared.
Basically, n squared.
So, to get a precise complexity,
we should solve this recursion,
but it will end up being the
same thing as this intuition,
n cubic.
OK, so now, this is the magic.
So Strassen, in 1969, came
up with this algorithm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Each of these is
a half n by half n matrix.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: So Strassen came
up with this algorithm.
He somehow defined M1
through M7, seven matrices,
in this way.
I can't provide any
intuition, because I
didn't come up with this.
And, somehow, with
those seven matrices,
he can reconstruct, he
can compute all the four
submatrices in C.
And it's not very just
interesting to check it,
because the algorithm
is definitely correct.
But let's just do one of them.
OK, how about this one.
So C21 is M2 plus M4.
So M2 plus M4.
So M2 will have
A12 B11, A22 B11.
So M4, there's A22 minus
B11, so that cancels out.
So we're left with
A21 B11 plus A22 B21.
That's the correct answer.
So this, I guess, is a
very clever algorithm.
You have to work in
that area for 10 years
to come up with this so
that's not our concern.
Our goal is to analyze
this algorithm.
What's the complexity of it?
So does anyone understand
this recursion?
Can someone tell me, what's
the recursion for this part,
for this Strassen algorithm?
We have the original
problem, and we have some--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So since each
of the M 1 through 7
only require one
multiplication, you'll
need to solve seven subproblems,
so 7T n over 2 plus O n
squared.
LING REN: That's
absolutely correct.
Everyone gets this?
So what Strassen did, is he
came up with the seven matrices.
Each one requires only
one multiplication.
So we have seven subproblems,
instead of eight,
and that's going to give us
a benefit, an improvement.
So the question now becomes,
how do I solve this recursion?
Given this recursion, how
do I know its complexity?
And same question there.
Anyone want to give it a try?
So that's going to be covered
in a third topic, which
is Master Theorem.
So Master Theorem
does exactly that.
All it does is, given the
recursion, a and T of n
over b, plus some
work for merging,
where a and b are constants, it
directly tell you what T of n
is, in some cases.
So I'll first write the formula.
Master Theorem actually
has three cases.
The first case, fn,
is order n raised
to c, where c is
less than log b of a.
Then, Master Theorem says, it's
complexity is theta log b of a.
Second case, fn is theta
nc log K, where c is,
log b is equal to b of a,
then it's complexity is n
raised to c log K plus 1 n.
You don't necessarily
have to copy them,
because you just
find them anywhere.
And the third case,
you can imagine,
it's the only remaining
case, which is, fn is large,
it's omega n raised to c, where
c is greater than log b of a.
Then, Master Theorem says,
its complexity, the complexity
of Tn, is theta fn.
So, intuitively, if fn
is not too much work,
then it's basically
this recursion,
what recursion gives you.
If fn dominates, fn is
the biggest component,
then Tn is, roughly,
on the order of fn,
and there's a case
in the middle.
Now, let's see why
that is the case.
I'll only cover one case, here.
So, again, we are going
to draw a recursion
tree, because that is very
useful in all the recursion
problems.
So we start with a
problem of size n,
and we break them into
problem size n over b.
So on and so forth.
What's the size of
this subproblem?
So that recursion represents a
class of recursive algorithm.
Every time it
breaks the problem,
it reduced the problem
size by a factor
of b, so what do I have here?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: n over b squared.
So on and so forth.
So what is a, in this graph?
AUDIENCE: 3.
LING REN: 3, think so?
3.
a is just a branching
factor of this tree.
I keep going.
Finally, I will
reach my base case.
So my next question is, after
how many levels of recursion
will I reach a base
case of size 1?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Log b of [INAUDIBLE]?
LING REN: Log b of--
OK, so, here is n over b, n
over b square, next one n over b
cubic, so on and so forth.
So, say, this last level it
Tth level, than the problems
size is n over--
we raise to T, and we want that
to be a constant, so what is T?
AUDIENCE: Log b on n.
LING REN: Log b of n.
Now, this is the recursion
tree, and we have that fn
among the emerging work to do.
So, here, we have to do fn
work, to merge these a results
to the solution
of our problem, n.
Then, we have f- what's the
emerging work for this level,
for this part of the tree?
This is my problem size.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: n over b, right.
And we have a of them.
OK, so on and so forth.
So, then, we know what is Tn.
Let's just enumerate all
the work we have to do.
So on the first level,
we have to do fn.
OK, on second level, af n of b--
sorry, n over b.
And what's the next level?
We have how many subproblems?
Speak louder.
AUDIENCE: a squared.
LING REN: a square
subproblems, and each of them
is n over b squared.
And, finally, I
reach my last level.
They are all base cases, so
I have a raised to T of them,
because I defined T to
be my depth of the tree.
And each of them is T of 1.
OK, so that's Tn.
I'm not entirely happy
with this formula,
because I have this
beautiful pattern, here,
except for that last guy.
It's add one a and divide
one b, blah, blah, blah.
So I'm going to
change this T into f.
Can I do that?
Because it's [INAUDIBLE]
is the same, right?
T1 is a constant,
f1 is also constant.
Then, I get my beautiful
form, where it's a sum from i
equals 0 to T.
What's in the sum?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: a raised
to i, f of n over b1.
Everyone gets that?
Now, you can roughly see
why we have three cases.
So let me deal with
the first case.
The first case says, fn
is order n raised to c.
What does that mean?
It means this guy here
is sigma a raised to n,
then this is what's
in my f raised to c.
There should be order, here, but
everything has order before it,
so I just omit that.
So it actually
should be this, OK?
So this, because n
raised to c is actually
independent of the
sum, I can pull it out.
And what am I left with?
Is that correct?
Now, this is a sum of
geometric sequence.
We know how to
solve that, but we
need to check whether this ratio
is greater or larger than 1,
or if it's equal to 1.
And what is this ratio?
The case tells us.
So c is less than log b of a.
That means b raised
to c is less than b
raised to this guy,
which is a, right?
So we know our denominator
is smaller than or numerator.
So this is an increasing
sequence, right?
So what we have
is n raised to c,
then that thing
raised to t minus 1
divided by this thing minus 1.
But they are all constants.
Are everyone familiar
with this formula.
of geometric sequence?
OK, so that's what we have.
Next, we have t
equals log b of n.
That means b raised
to t is n, correct?
So, then, b raised to t is
n, then we have raised to c,
they cancel out.
What do we have?
I want to make sure
everyone's following.
AUDIENCE: is it a over t?
LING REN: A raised to t.
No questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
do that stuff again?
LING REN: OK, let
me do that again.
It's actually a
raised to t, and then
n over bt raised to c, right?
AUDIENCE: How did you get
from the line above that?
LING REN: This one to here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LING REN: Oh, it's the
sum of geometric sequence,
so if I have 1 plus q plus q
squared, all the way to qt,
it's qt plus 1, I guess-- or
t, I don't remember very well--
minus 1, then q minus 1.
I guess this should be t plus 1.
So this is what we're doing.
So this is our q minus 1,
and divided by q minus 1,
they are all constants, so
I don't care about them.
So a raised plus this
thing raised to c,
but we said that b raised
to t is equal to n,
so we're just left
with a raised to t.
And what is t?
t is log b of n.
I can write it as log
a of n over log a of b.
Everyone familiar with that?
That means log a
of n, log b of a.
This is when I flip them.
So this, what is that?
AUDIENCE: n.
LING REN: That is n.
OK, we're done.
Are we?
Not exactly, because I
have an order here, right?
So everything is ordered.
If you only care about
order, big O, then it's fine.
But that theorem
says theta, so you
have to prove it the other way,
that it's no less than that.
I'm not going to do that.
It's not very hard.
Next, I'm going to apply
this theorem to the two
problems we left here.
So let's apply Master
Theorem to this recurrence.
I think you are still
looking at that side.
So what is the a, b, c for this?
a is 8, b is 2, right?
And c is 2.
Log b of a is 3, so that's which
case of the Master Theorem?
So the theorem says
it should be n raised
to log b of a, which is 3, OK?
Now, what we have here,
can I remind someone
to do that for me?
Want to give it a try?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OK, so we have
a equals 7, b equals 2,
and c equals 2, like before.
And, now, we want to see whether
c equals 2 is less than log b
of a, which is log 2 of 7.
Pretty sure that's
still the case.
So we should just get
n to the log 2 of 7.
LING REN: Yeah, exactly.
So, yeah.
Yeah, thank you. let's give
him a round of applause.
So log 2 of 7 is
definitely greater than 2.
Why?
Because log 2 of 4 is 2, right?
So this happens to be n raised
to 2.80, and many other digits,
but it's less than n cubic.
And, just for knowledge purpose,
this is no longer the best.
It was the best,
when it was proposed,
and, well, researchers
in that area
have got it down to
n raised to 2.35.
I think 2.37, first, then 2.35.
I'm not following the
literature very closely,
so maybe it's 2.34 now.
So I should have one
more thing to cover,
but I think we are
running out of time.
Sorry about that.
I can post it.
So the last thing
we should do is,
remember, we have this
medium finding algorithm,
where we have a recurrence,
which is, I think,
10 over 5, some ceiling, and
then plus this [INAUDIBLE]
n plus theta n.
And we want to solve
this recursion,
but we cannot apply
Master Theorem.
Apparently, it's
not the right form.
So when Master
Theorem doesn't apply,
we have to study
it case by case.
Let me see if I have
time to do that.
OK, I think I probably do.
To solve that case,
first, can someone
tell me, what's the
definition of theta?
We have to go back to the
definition to solve that.
What does theta even mean?
So if I say fn is theta
n, what do I really mean?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's tightly bounded,
so you can move the [INAUDIBLE]
to either side.
LING REN: So it means I can
find some K1 and K2 such
that this holds when n
gets sufficiently large.
OK, so, now, we're
going to do induction.
Assuming, for all the small
n less than capital N,
my Tn is bounded by
this K2 and K1 thing.
Then, my next step is, T of
this capital N would be bounded.
I'll do the right side first.
It will be bounded by
K2 n5 ceiling, plus K2.
[INAUDIBLE] in a second
term, n plus another theta n.
So, we know, that means it's
bounded by some other number.
I'll say A2, then.
That's the definition
of theta n.
Then, I want this to be--
sorry, all of them
should be capital
N. Capital N, Capital N.
I want this to be smaller
than K2 capital N.
So let me redo this first step.
This is roughly 5 of K2 plus
7 over 10 K2, plus A2 of n,
plus a bunch of constants
that I don't care.
I want it to be
smaller than K2 of n.
Can I reach that?
Of course I can, right?
If I select a K2 to be
greater than all we have here,
what is this?
This is 9 over 10
K2 plus A2, right?
So if I select the K2 to be
greater than 10 times A2--
is everyone following that?
When n is sufficiently large,
Tn should be bounded by A2 n.
That's the induction.
I am assuming, when n is
smaller than capital N,
I have solved them.
So I can use these two,
and I solve the next step.
So there's the other side,
which is very similar.
I'm not going to
go through that.
All right, so that's
all for today.
And just to quickly
recap, we went
through the weighted
interval scheduling,
and the Strassen algorithm,
Master Theorem and applying
Master Theorem, and that case
study of a new recursion.
OK, thanks,
everyone, for coming.